[Aplausos]
el pasado 14 de noviembre el gobierno
británico y las autoridades de la unión
europea hicieron público su acuerdo de
ruptura un acuerdo de ni más ni menos
que 500 85 páginas que la verdad no han
servido para contentar prácticamente a
nadie ahora bien que supone este acuerdo
están los partidarios del derecho y
contentos que podemos esperar se alejan
definitivamente los temores a salir a no
pactada en este vídeo os lo contamos
[Aplausos]
holmes
[Música]
[Aplausos]
un acuerdo que no gusta a casi nadie
y el acuerdo alcanzado entre el gobierno
británico y la unión europea no es ni
muy bueno ni muy malo para ninguna de
las partes se ha planteado básicamente
para dar certidumbre durante los
próximos años mientras se negocia un
acuerdo definitivo si lo habéis
escuchado bien este no es el acuerdo
final si este divorcio promete ser muy
pero que muy largo acostumbrados al
ritmo de bruselas
10 y su altitud y twitter
lo que se ha pactado ha sido
fundamentalmente una especie de acuerdo
de separación que fija algunas claves
para que algún día se pueda alcanzar un
acuerdo de ruptura total o tal vez no
porque una de las cosas que contempla
este documento es un periodo de
transición que en la práctica podría
llegar a extenderse y extenderse en el
tiempo si así es en un momento lo vamos
a ver pero antes de nada hay que decir
que este acuerdo ha sentado fatal en la
política británica este acuerdo no le
gusta prácticamente a nadie ni a los
partidarios del presidente ni a quienes
se oponen a él
vamos que teresa me haya conseguido casi
lo imposible poner de acuerdo a casi
todo el mundo sobre que el acuerdo ha
sido una verdadera chufa
en internet
site
dimisiones en cadena en el gobierno de
may por el acuerdo del éxito y es que
veréis no es que en sí mismo lo acordado
sea muy malo para el reino unido no lo
es pero la sensación general es que el
gobierno británico no ha estado a la
altura y no les han parado de encajar
goles la negociación ha sido algo así
como una partida de póquer donde los
británicos enseñaban sus cartas al resto
de jugadores antes siquiera de empezar a
jugar
y les dan el kin mons
único switch por ejemplo activaron el
artículo 50 el artículo de salida
demasiado pronto no tenían ninguna
obligación de hacerlo podrían haberse
tomado todo el tiempo del mundo pero lo
activaron sin tener nada preparado y los
plazos empezaron a correr en su contra
luego en la negociación los líderes
británicos han dado tumbos no han tenido
una estrategia clara y sólo les ha
faltado regalar sus calcetines y es que
amigos theresa may ni siquiera era
partidario del break shit ella apoyó la
permanencia del reino unido en la unión
europea como puede dirigir
de separación a alguien que se opone a
él y considera que es malo creo con cada
fibra de mi ser que la estrategia
trazada es la mejor para el país y para
todos los ciudadanos mantendremos el
control de nuestras fronteras el control
de nuestro dinero el control de nuestras
leyes y el control de nuestra
agricultura y nuestra pesca teresa mi
primera ministra del reino unido- vale
es verdad seamos justos en esta partida
los británicos no tenían la mejor jugada
pero tampoco una tan mala
reino unido es la segunda mayor economía
de toda la unión europea de hecho su
economía es más grande que las economías
de los diecinueve países más pequeños de
la unión juntas comercia más con el
resto del mundo que con todos los países
de la unión los países europeos se
hinchan exportarles todo tipo de cosas a
los británicos y londres es la capital
financiera del mundo no me digáis que no
son argumentos de peso pues a pesar de
ello que déjame y no ha conseguido
prácticamente nada de lo que se propuso
por ejemplo teresa me prometió que iba a
firmar acuerdos de libre comercio y
ahora no van a poder hacerlo como poco
hasta el año 2021 dijo que reino unido
no pondría más dinero y ahora han
acordado que los británicos pagarán más
de 50 mil millones de dólares aseguró
que el país no quedaría bajo la
jurisdicción de los tribunales europeos
de justicia y eso también tendrá que
esperar y así podríamos continuar con
una larga lista de fracasos
ahora bien puede que os estáis
preguntando qué ha ocurrido cómo se
pueden hacer las cosas tan mal pues lo
cierto es que teresa may ya lo sabéis no
era partidaria del break sí pero sí
tenía una obsesión controlar férreamente
las fronteras fijaos en su estilo cuando
era ministra de interior vamos a dar a
los inmigrantes ilegales una recepción
realmente hostil lo decía de los
inmigrantes ilegales pero venía a
referirse también a los inmigrantes
europeos pues bien fue su obsesión
entonces y ha sido su obsesión durante
todo el proceso
de hecho theresa may ha prometido
reducir la entrada anual de inmigrantes
de forma drástica y esa es la parte a la
que más prioridad le ha dado en la
negociación no le ha importado para ello
ceder en todas las demás cuestiones a
cambio de que el gobierno británico
controle la entrada de personas y eso sí
lo ha conseguido claro que esto es algo
que le importa a ella y le importaban
los británicos en 2016 pero en los
últimos años
ocupación por los extranjeros se ha
desplomado ahora en un momento tan
importante los británicos tienen un
gobierno que ha situado como prioridad
algo que a ellos cada vez les importa
menos fijaos
[Música]
aunque eso sí atención importante todos
aquellos europeos que estéis viviendo el
reino unido- mantendréis vuestros
derechos pero bien llegados a este punto
seguro que muchos de vosotros os estáis
preguntando por las luces y las sombras
por cuáles son los principales puntos
acordados bien veamos los
[Música]
por lo tanto se nos defina bien
las luces las sombras y las incógnitas a
pesar de lo dicho hasta ahora conviene
insistir en un matiz aunque el acuerdo
alcanzado no le gusta a casi nadie no es
ni mucho menos tan malo para el reino
unido está hecho con el preacuerdo del
éxito sector español desgraciadamente un
gobierno otro europeísta tendrá que
votar que no de hecho poco a poco se
están disipando los temores sobre si el
break sheet podría ser catastrófico si
aún hay riesgo de que se produzca un
break shit duro una separación por las
bravas pero lo que nos dice este acuerdo
es que si hay voluntad para evitar que
las cosas se desmadren reino unido tiene
mucho que perder pero también la unión
europea
pero bien básicamente lo más importante
que se ha acordado es que a partir del
29 de marzo de 2019 día en el que el
reino unido- dejará de pertenecer a la
unión europea dará comienzo un periodo
de transición que durará hasta el 31 de
diciembre del año 2020 periodo en el que
las cosas seguirán prácticamente como
hasta ahora no habrá aduanas ni
aranceles ni barreras de ningún tipo y
es más si durante ese tiempo no se
alcanza un acuerdo definitivo a partir
del 1 de enero del año 2021 la unión
aduanera se prolongará indefinidamente
al menos hasta que las partes decidan lo
contrario si de esta forma reino unido-
deberá cumplir las regulaciones europeas
sin poder siquiera votar las pero tendrá
más margen de maniobra y mantendrá su
acceso al mercado común no podrá afirmar
acuerdos de libre comercio con otros
países mientras forme parte de esta
unión aduanera pero si va a poder
negociar los
además aunque reino unido- tendrá que
asumir determinados compromisos el
cumplimiento de éstos dependerá
fundamentalmente del regateo político
tal y como ocurre hoy en día con suiza
es decir aunque reino unido- acepta una
armonización importante de sus normas
con las de la unión europea su margen de
maniobra va a ser mucho mayor que hoy en
día
[Música]
esto en parís y en berlín lo saben y
precisamente por ello están preocupados
porque londres sepa aprovechar estos
años para rearmar su posición y ganar
ventajas competitivas por eso en el
acuerdo han incluido dos puntos muy
importantes sobre esta cuestión
primero aunque reinó unido- rompa con la
unión aduanera europea irlanda del norte
continuará formando parte de ella así
que el reino unido tendría que estar
dispuesto a tener aduanas e incluso
aranceles entre sus propios territorios
eso sí lo que no dice el acuerdo es cómo
lograría bruselas que londres no hiciera
la vista gorda
segundo la cuestión clave con el acuerdo
actual reino unido- no podrá romper
unilateralmente la unión aduanera así
que más que un break sheet sin el
consentimiento de bruselas estaremos
ante un medio break city
y además insisto durante todo el periodo
de tiempo que dure la permanencia de
reino unido a la unión aduanera europea
tendrá que aceptar y cumplir las normas
que se aprueben en bruselas normas sobre
las que londres no podrá decir nada
normas que los británicos no votarán y
sobre cuyo cumplimiento en última
instancia tendrá competencia el tribunal
de justicia de la unión europea de ahí
que muchos críticos digan que este
acuerdo hace del país un estado vasallo
pero esto no es todo
[Música]
como ya hemos dicho los otros puntos
importantes del acuerdo es que reinó
unido- pagará una indemnización de 50
mil millones de dólares a la unión
europea y que también respetará los
derechos de los tres millones de
europeos que viven en este país
en fin estas son las principales
cuestiones que aborda el acuerdo y las
principales luces y sombras para el
reino unido
claro que aún no es un acuerdo aprobado
y tal vez nunca lo sea no es aceptable
espanyol desgraciadamente un gobierno
pro europeísta tendrá que votar que no
es de su capacidad porque eso es una
cuestión que afecta a la esencia de
nuestro país este acuerdo no es
especialmente bueno para el reino unido
que ni siquiera consigue una desconexión
plena con la unión europea pero genera
certidumbre e incrementa la capacidad de
maniobra de londres y le permite ganar
tiempo para compensar los errores
cometidos en cualquier caso si hay una
cosa que parece clara es que theresa may
nunca debió liderar este proceso había
alternativas y de ellas hablaremos aquí
en visual político pero ahora turno para
ti estás de acuerdo con que bruselas
parte con londres el break sheet déjame
tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta si este vídeo
te ha resultado interesante darle al
botón de like un saludo y hasta la
próxima
en walk of fame por lasarte 61 la pinada
bayern